ça fait cinq ans que je dis qu'on va
dans le mur alors quand on va dans le
mur ça fait mal mais il pouvait changer
à tout moment on pouvait après les
municipales modifier les choses on
pouvait après les régionales modifier
les choses on pouvait ne pas faire la
loi elle conneries on pouvait ne pas
faire de 500 e
on pouvait ne pas s'engluer dans
l'histoire de la déchéance de
nationalité
on avait tout la gauche en 2012 tout
absolument tout le sénat l'assemblée les
villes les régions et aux l'on nous a
tous fait perdre hollande pendant cinq
ans a trahi la gauche et pendant salle
quand on la gauche au lieu de faire une
politique de gauche
elle a fait une politique de droite et
quand on fait une politique de droite on
perd comme on vient de perdre
j'ai essayé d'éviter ça avec toute la
gauche socialiste pendant cinq ans j'ai
essayé d'éviter cette catastrophe mais
qu'on vienne pas nous dire que c'est à
nous la responsabilité comme le monsieur
josé me le dire
mais ça pour qu'on a été entraînée par
le mahb à dammarie ça prouve pas du tour
c'est notre politique qui est en cause
la gauche socialiste elle a tout fait
pour éviter ça tout fait et aussi on va
dans le mur demander pourquoi cambadélis
si on va dans le mur demander pourquoi
hollandais à valls si on va dans le mur
demander pourquoi marisol touraine
elle passe à travers les gouttes mais je
m'étonne pourquoi il fallait embaucher
des dizaines de milliers d'infirmières
au lieu de donner des milliards au
patronat il faut l'élever effectivement
offert l'emploi public au lieu de
prétendre faire l'emploi privé par le
biais des grandes entreprises qui n'en
n'ont rien fait alors il faut pas
confondre c'est pas la gauche qui est en
cause c'est ce que la droite à la tête
du parti socialiste a fait pendant cinq
ans qui est en cause
écoutez on va on va rénover ce parti
l'eau ils y vivent ou changer de nom
s'ils laissent le nom je reprends parce
que moi je suis socialiste
comprenez mais pas socialiste comme il
disait à la macro - la hollande ni à la
valse des soldats qui doivent
effectivement dégager sinon vous dégagez
a un sens